the obvious career possibility so we all
have a move that probably makes squiggly
sense when I was at Microsoft it was my
manager's job like that's what people
thought I should do and it seemed
sensible to do now I run my company the
sensible move for me to make is actually
to stay in my job because it's growing
my company is growing and so I will grow
with it that's the sensible move for me
to make the reason I want people to
explore this one a little bit more is
because a lot of people assume that
because it's obvious it's the right move
for them to make so they take on their
manager's job or they go for that
promotion because they they're currently
a junior and they should be a senior and
all those kind of things or I just stay
in my role because it's obvious that
it's growing and I should stay in it and
actually maybe that role doesn't
actually need what you want to be known
for but the strength maybe that rle
doesn't align with the things that
really drive and motivate you back to
your values so it'll be a good fit for
you if it fits with your values and
strengths if if it doesn't then it might
look good on paper but it's not going to
be good for
[Music]
you